quarantine in israel offices are shot
for a couple of months
kids in current time at home
with my wife myself and i find within
myself with four months to
i know i think five months to end of
cash
with zero pipeline for investment that
was one of the toughest moments
make a long story show
amazing group of people atlantico
grew more than 130 percent during 2020
without increasing the head count even
in one person quarantined from home
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders this is a very special one a
story of entrepreneurship resilience and
grit
meet zviki benishai co-founder and ceo
of laitiko
sviki founded lightico to empower
businesses to effectively sell and
service customers completely in the
first call
zwiki is an expert in contact center
management technologies in the field of
innovation and analytics
his experiences in the contact center
management and technologies have
sharpened his industry knowledge and his
innovations have impacted millions of
customer interactions
prior to lightiko zviki led product
innovation and deployment across leading
cx companies including nice systems
netcom and xb viki benicia welcome to 20
minute leaders the ceo
of lightiko how are you
doing great doing great is you could say
nighttime that's when we start
when you're doing business from israel
and selling to the states this is like
your morning
it's kind of weird to be a vampire but
you
there's way too much for us to talk
about i'm going to cut straight to the
chase tell me about lightiko tell me
what you're doing
i i'll take a minute then to share my
own obsession with the work that you're
doing which i think is phenomenal
and then we're going to get to some
really fun entrepreneurial stuff
okay cool so lighting we've we've
designed i think something like six
years of ago we just named it we didn't
know what we're building but uh we just
named it it's a digital completion
platform and
where businesses especially b2c facing
businesses such as financial services
insurance telecommunication lending they
have lots of different processes with
their customers very clunky very
old-fashioned
heavily regulated those are done via
paper faxes emails etc a long
long lost channel lighting built a
single platform to
enable the building of any digital flow
that replaces those manual tds
long lasting journeys and gives
every organization the ability to do
rapid digital transformation
taking all those old processes and
turning them into new and digital
without no
any any coding in a very fast and uh
and efficient manner that's that's like
the kind of glance
you know just with a few numbers how big
of a market are we talking about here
uh how many companies are are you know
thinking about this or are having
trouble with this asked us consumers how
are we experiencing this in the in the
digital world and where is this going
when we started evaluating the market
and you know sometimes
people say that the total addressable
market is nonsense because you can't
really understand it until you get into
it but when we evaluated it we're
talking about the 25 to 50 billion
dollar market
only from evaluating the the five key
verticals that we operate in which is
health care insurance banking
lending and telecommunication yeah the
world is big so we believe there's a
much larger time but 25 to 50 billion is
enough for now
okay and work for a lot of years without
even touching this stamp so
100 now one of the things that i think
is important to understand in the
context of light eco and your market is
that this is a
an increasingly growing market you're
having more and more organizations that
are that are
becoming uh you know they're getting
into the cloud with telecommunications
the expectation from consumers is to
have more front-facing technologies that
enable us to have a smoother experience
which is what a lot of these companies
are not able to deliver themselves
especially in insurance
and healthcare and a lot of these
age-old industries that are working with
massive infrastructure that just doesn't
enable them to do that right
yeah i totally i totally agree it's it's
not a matter of um
of the infrastructure or the way that
they're built it's it's a matter of just
the
how you perceive the problem um now you
want to on board a customer to a bank
let's say as an example the first thing
you need to do verify the customer
authenticity that's
that's the human that they that that is
talking with the person
afterwards you need to verify that the
identification document is legit
afterwards you need to collect
information you use some kind of form
technology you need to sign documents
acknowledge the
terms and conditions you need to collect
payments all of those are being done
with siloed systems
if you want to connect all of those
together you need lots of i.t resources
and lots of core developers in order to
build those flows
when you look at at an insurance company
that has
thousands and thousands of different
processes we are talking about
years of development what we've said is
stop
let's build a platform that enables
every person to build all of those
without coding
and that creates a way to take that
digital process instead of three months
into a minute you're in
right and so at the end when we're
looking at customer expectations so what
have you learned
while building out lightico about us
consumers when we're interacting with
these large businesses
and how is that consumer you know
expectation shifted i guess
either helped or didn't help your
mission
first of all the consumers are much more
demanding than what i
expected them to be when we started like
oh and myself and dakota and my
co-founders
um we can say that they've been spoiled
and it's it's a cliche everybody are
talking about that everybody are saying
but the customer that
buys a home insurance in hippo or any
other insurance and lemonade in five
minutes will not
tolerate a three-day cycle to join
a life insurance policy it just won't
work for the long term so customers are
looking for
the more efficient ways of of doing
business
they want a fast and painless
and delighting experience that they are
used to from netflix and amazon all
those other vendors and that only
becomes harder and harder because
kids that are going up today to be 18
and
get their first insurance policy join
the college and open their first bank
account
they do not understand what the fax is
they don't have a pc and they don't have
an email
they don't have an email there is no
reason they used to have an email to
open their facebook account or instagram
but now it works on their mobile number
so they don't even need an email
anymore it's a different type of
customer that requires a different
kind of tool set and because enterprises
and mid-sized companies are not as fast
as the consumers
who created a system that bridges the
gap between them and the consumers
to give them that experience that is
delighting without
the need of overhauling your entire end
in your infrastructure
let's take that digital completion
platform and connect the old to the new
and there you go amazing so so take me
back to the founding of lightico
and and there's going to be some
interesting moments where
i'd love to just let you speak through
them because i think they're going to be
both entertaining but also very
educational uh you know to both myself
and a lot of others
that are listening to this and so tell
me a little bit about the founding of
lightico and
a few interesting moments along the way
lighting there's so many interesting
moments i can
i i can start first of all lighting it
was a school project
which is always always fun we went uh
i started my mba i think it was the
second year of my mba and
i joined up with a guy called omri we
had a few classes together and then we
said oh there's the entrepreneurship
department let's go there and uh we
heard there is kind of like a small
accelerator
that we can do like uh like we're
establishing a company building a deck
doing a demo day presenting to potential
investors et cetera
and i usually don't like uh playing
so what i've done is is called justin
and
and volvo and told them guys they worked
with me in one of the previous
roles that i had told them guys we have
a project at school and they allow us to
bring people from the outside let's
build the company that's what's the
stuff of lighting
we gathered up for people thought about
an idea took it through the accelerated
we
got ourselves with a product and when
when all the other kids were playing
because they playing because they built
decks and and everything else
and very smart guys but we were kind of
more crazy
and so we got out of that three months
with the product with a customer and
uh with lots of ambition moving forward
fast forward something like five years
100 plus employees
millions of dollars in arr and a bright
future with a fantastic
company with a great culture that's
that's kind of like how lighting
started and along the way from this
school project to to more than 100
employees and millions of dollars of are
interesting a few moments along the way
is that what
ben ben horowitz said yeah ben harvey he
said you're it's over moments we
had so many of them
you know sometimes you sit already in
those moments i can't i can't describe
as a ceo than um how
how alone you feel in that in those
moments when you understand something
that everybody else don't really
understand because you don't want to
reflect your feelings outside you know
after the fact you can tell it
like here online but uh
we opened our new offices it was
february 25th
2020. um 1000
square meters if it's launched in the us
i don't know how to convert
miles it's a lot good it's a lot it's a
big
big office renovated amazing
three-term on the desk for a crazy
b
round um a few days afterwards the stock
market in the us
drops because of carbon
quarantine in israel offices are shot
for a couple of months
kids in current time at home
with my wife myself with three terms
that were
pulled immediately by the visas that are
telling
we're sorry we do not understand what
are going to be the multipliers in a
year from now
we don't know how to build our
investment this is which is totally
understandable it's not the time
i'm angry that's just the reality and i
find within myself with four months to
you know i think five months to end of
cash
with zero pipeline for investment that
was one of the toughest moments
make a long story show
amazing group of people atlantico
grew more than 130 percent during 2020
without increasing the head count even
in one person quarantined from home
and crazy executive leadership that
worked with me
with over 50 vcs in the pipeline
all of them remotely from tel aviv to
the us and uk
which eventually got us to a very good b
round that is now being extended
and that got us through that very very
tough year
so lots of fighting stories lots of um
heroic stories of getting top-notch
customers in uncertainty when you don't
even have
email access uh to deliver um
a stuttering year in the most horrible
conditions ever so that's that's the
strength
of a strong and small group of people
and luckily to be leading them
take me back to that moment where you're
getting those term sheets pulled from
you
obviously the correspondence with the
vcs
it's it's in your inbox right and you
have
more than 100 employees that are waiting
for the news or
are waiting to see what what will happen
and you have an executive team with you
vice presidents of the company and
friends that colleagues that have
grew the company with you and you and
you have these doubts that maybe
we might not get through this right five
months to go and
covet is just starting what do we do
what what is what is that like what do
you what do you do in that moment
first of all you call your friends at
the board because they have amazing
investors i tell them guys this is the
situation
that's vc one two three just pull the
turn we have a situation when we
have
end of cash first of all what do we do
you need to uh extend the cash without
dropping any person because
like as a culture we don't have any
disposable person we can say there is no
um
person that uh okay we can we can just
let go
there's no such thing so um we've built
did the math a few unpaid leaves for a
very short
period and 20 salary reduction
from myself downwards to everybody and
and the speech to the entire company
telling everybody
very transparently what happened what is
the situation
what is the length and getting
everything clear a doubt with everybody
and explaining to everybody right
you know most of the people in in the
world lost their job so first of all
we're lucky to have a job that's
for all of us and from that moment we
have a mission together and it was
really together
we need to get through this calling the
board
in parallel telling them that's the
situation that's the burn it's going to
go down to here
everybody are okay with it employees are
okay
very motivated we need that extra layer
of cash to get us
through 2020 and towards 2021 and i got
an acknowledgement from my board members
then i guess guy
sneaky we're covering for you that was
the first thing that got us the release
employees not even one quitted and there
were lots of
opportunities to move between companies
in um during coven
not even a single employee quit during
that time um
i got amazing encouraging notes whatsapp
messages text messages and emails from
everybody
which were very encouraging encouraging
and i can say that they
got me through it so the people
fledico helped me and the founding team
and
executive leadership through that that
period with staggering results and
it was just try to be calm and after
everything we've been through up until
your skin is sick it's not it's not
it's not like it was years ago so we
know how to handle stress and
and uncertainty that was a very high
level of stress and uncertainty but uh
anyway we we got we got three tough
times um
but it only got a stronger and more
united as a company so we're very ready
to
to conquer the world and
with your internal leadership team as
you're progressing through
well we said over 50 vcs unbelievable
what what is what does leadership look
like at that point
so what what is the communication with
the leadership team how do you keep
the other leaders motivated right i mean
that they're really saying you in the
trenches
how do you work through them day by day
through 50 vcs
first of all uh you're taking most of
the other lifting
as a ceo so it means that my first
responsibility was
um to build a framework that takes all
the data and build it with the
executives within a two to three weeks
time
time frame luckily for me i was just at
the end of the funding route with terms
so i had everything already prepared
build data room and just get them
out of the noise giving them the ability
to work and pull them only for specific
discussions when i needed to brag with
my amazing executive team so that that
was kind of it taking most of the heavy
lifting
doing all the calls i think i was at
this balcony
everybody can see with my plants this is
where i was
for covered entire covered
in rain and in in in the sun
and just speaking with investors and
telling them about ladyco with a very
hard situation that every person that
comes into the latico offices sees the
people sit down for spur
falls in love and you can't really show
it
via zoom and that was one of the biggest
struggles but eventually we got
a fantastic investor that's ox vc
in the states joined by harmony you know
oxford scene in in london
uh joined by capital one ventures which
were customers that also decided to
to participate and how many venture
partners and so many good friends and
all the internals participated
and we got three so wow and strong
leadership
uh making that separation giving them
the space to work and they did an
amazing job
while taking most of the heavy lifting
and pulling them only
for for specific discussions
also it it drives even more pleasure
because it feels like you're alone
and it's all up to you and actually it
was all up to each and every one of us
and
we got through it together what did you
learn about yourself during that time
that i even more persistent um
crazy person that that i thought i am
it was an impact seriously looking back
impossible tasks the amount of stress
that that a person has with all the
surroundings it's covered it's not going
out of work there's no
no no school no kindergarten everything
happens in the house everything boils up
and we managed to both work
this kind of tells you that there is no
thing that can break you
and open right let's see moving forward
wow
it's vicky i loved this episode thank
you so much for the time and the energy
and
for for coming and sharing sharing this
with me i have a few more questions
about about yourself
and i wanted you to take me back to your
childhood what what really fascinated
you as a kid
so first of all uh lots of um
things fascinated me i grew up in
battiam it is suburb
next to tel aviv and i think two minutes
walk from the beach
so the beach fascinated me it was a big
big
big choice every morning do i go to the
beach or to school
uh i chose the beach you can see hence
my color i was born white
and so the beach fascinated me i love
the quiet i love the waves i like i love
the relax still
till this day surfing and and just
chilling out there
and enjoying the the the cold water
second thing i like breaking things
about i was very very curious
electronics
breaking my pc to pieces getting it
connecting everything together
downloading
i had the first cd burner i used to
build a
uh to burn the cds for all of my class
uh i i was the first big technology very
early adopter so i was a geek a very
young geek um mainly around technology
nature
but technology beat it and you can see
up until today that's everything that
i'm doing
amazing and what inspires you today
it's it's a question that is just it has
cliche all over it
right but what inspires me are um
are two things seriously and live aside
famous people that are doing amazing
things that's always inspiring but i
think the little
and the little fact yeah how people
can work together in in being very
strong so
so every time i walk through our offices
in lydica and i think that's that's an
important i'm inspired
because what people can do when they
have a smart
infrastructure to work with and and a
good culture
is is just amazing what a group of
people can do is much more let's say the
oneplus one definitely is not too
um and and my kids they amaze me every
time
you're so smart the way that they are
just looking at them and looking at the
world they're growing into
and um and they inspire me amazing
that's uh those are the two things it's
vicky and what are three words that you
would use to describe yourself
crazy yet accountable crazy and
accountable i'm not going to repeat the
three words that you said before
which i which i might have liked better
but uh but i'll take it
i'll take this it's wiki seriously
what a journey
[Music]